while kim kardashian made her
relationship with pete davidson
instagram official last week it looks
like pete made it even more official
with ink
oh my god on sunday eagle eyed fans
noticed a tattoo on the saturday night
live star's chest spelling out kim
yeah there's no denying it
k-i-m people
now the 28 year old comedian hasn't
confirmed if the tat is real but either
way it's pretty sweet so we'll just have
to wait and see
of course fans caught a glimpse of pete
rocking his girlfriend's name close to
his heart when the king of staten island
star's friend and saturday night live
writer dave cyrus posted this alleged
text exchange between pete and kim's
estranged husband kanye west we have to
thank kim
after the grammy winner fired off a
series of posts alleging that his ex
wasn't allowing him to see their
children and was allowing their oldest
daughter north to continue using tick
tock against his will pete allegedly
decided to step in in the screenshot
which has since been deleted pete asks
the rapper to calm down adding that kim
is literally the best mother quote i've
decided i'm not gonna let you treat us
this way anymore and i'm done being
quiet grow the [ __ ] up so how did kanye
take all that
i'm just extremely happy can you tell by
my face
according to the alleged text convo he
kept it brief calling out pete for using
profanity and asking where are you right
now to which pete allegedly replied with
that shirtless selfie adding in bed with
your wife
at this point it's it's going too far
yeah yay addressed all that in a since
deleted post to instagram the boyfriend
texts me antagonizing me bragging about
being in bed
with
my wife but that alleged heated exchange
between kanye and pete ended with the
comedian asking the yeezy designer to
meet up so they could sort out their
differences
he texted me talking and bragging about
how he's in bed with my wife and i'm
like well who's watching
my children if he's texting me bragging
about being in bed with my wife
and and i thought this wasn't my wife no
more legally of course this all comes
after a judge granted kim's request to
be declared legally single
and on friday the reality star made it
instagram official with pete posting
these puckered up snaps there he is with
his head in the kkw beauty founder's lap
and that's pete holding up the camera
for a selfie while his girlfriend blows
a kiss i do what i want to do i care
only about
you know what makes me happy kim also
spoke out about her new love for the
first time last week during an interview
with variety
at the end of the day life is about
being happy
when asked if fans will get to see her
new relationship play out on her famous
family's new hulu series the kardashians
kim said the two haven't filmed together
yet but she's not opposed to it and on
monday a new trailer dropped and it
looks like fans have a whole lot to look
forward to when the new show premieres
april 14th
this is a relationship that i don't
think anybody saw coming from who are
you texting ken does his name rhyme with
feet
[Music]